in one hospital in barcelona patients
recovering from cobit 19 are relearning
basic motor skills
there's still so much we don't know
about the novel coronavirus
experts are confident that it primarily
attacks the lungs
but more and more scientists are finding
other lingering effects
even in the brain this is what physical
therapy looks like at valdez hebron
hospital
where doctors say recovery can take
months
respiratory
while many patients here spent weeks in
the icu they developed blood clots in
their lungs that led to strokes
so medical professionals are monitoring
all possible complications
from the moment patients arrive at the
hospital to the time they are discharged
62 year old daniel katie for example
spent 21 days in the icu in an induced
coma
he had several strokes
[Music]
after receiving post-covet
rehabilitation at the hospital
now he's able to walk and talk again
[Music]
many coveted patients here also suffered
from inflammation in the brain
survivor is currently in rehab after
spending 15 days sedated and intubated
he was told there would be little hope
a
[Music]
despite the difficulties in dealing with
the pandemic
dr sanchez says as patients get better
medical staff get a boost
in spain health officials have flattened
the curve
allowing medical experts to focus on the
rehabilitation of its survivors
meanwhile in the united states cases
continue to climb and icu beds are
filling up
you